you'll land the role in nantes land so I
get out of the car and I go and I pull
up to her we didn't have any phones then
this is 1983 right yeah I think so
84 and I pick up a payphone somewhere on
like Washington Boulevard and I call my
agent
it's like 6 o'clock like everyone's
office is about to close or 5:30 and I
call this guy and I go he goes how did
it go
and I said I think it went pretty well
it was pretty well he's they want to
hire you you [ __ ] they were sending
lady it idiot healer he would always
play for breath right and I go wow it's
exciting who's Ellison they want to make
the deal now we're gonna get 25 for the
pilot and 12 5 for the episode and I'm
like Jim Nabors I'm like I'm like golly
Wow 2,500 for the pilot twelve hundred
and fifty dollars a week and we'll make
on the TV show and he's like no you
idiot they're gonna pay you 25,000 to
the pilot 12,500 away tomorrow I
literally I felt like the ground sort
like rocking like oh like I'm gonna go
by drag to hold on to the paper and I'm
in the booth I'm like I'm like the
ground to [ __ ] you're oh my god
I'm gonna make more money in in a year
than my dad makes in ten years and sad